From HE explosions to molotov infernos, grenade
kills might be rare, but they’re always
awesome.
So not including impact kills, here are our
picks for the Top 10 Grenade Kills in CS:GO
History.
Let’s kick off our list with a long-distance
boom — check out roca’s
throwing arm as he detonates shroud.
Go long!
(Casting)
VP’s carpet bombing of drop room against
Titan takes number nine on the list. Oh,
and the fact that ScreaM accidentally ‘naded
his own team is just the icing on top of the
high-explosive cake.
(Casting)
Pasha’s explosion of Gambit drops in at
number 8.
Perfect timing, perfect camera work and BOOM! Beautiful.
(Casting)
It takes some kind of tactical clairvoyance
to ‘nade stack drop on the first round of
a game, but Dignitas did just that in our
pick for number 7.
(Casting)
Pronax’s iconic molly 3k against Cloud9
comes in at number 6 on the list.
Cloud9 might have misplayed the situation
badly, but you can’t deny this play has
lived on in its infamy.
(Casting)
While the play itself is pretty standard,
Happy’s Defuse-Stopping ‘nade earns number
five because of the stakes in which it happened.
Even in a key round in the finals of a Major,
Happy didn’t miss. Kobe!
(Casting)
Want to see a thing of beauty?
Check out this take of A-site Cache by Team
Acer, whose perfect Molotov placements leave
AlienTech no choice but to burn.
(Casting)
Angel’s destruction of e-Frag.net’s
boost stack is a slam-dunk for number three.
It’s seldom we see three kills with one
‘nade, and the 80 damage on Spyleader is
just a sweet bonus.
(Casting)
TaZ’s roasting of TSM takes number two on
the list not only because it’s a great play,
but for the hilarious commentary by James Bardolph.
(Casting)
Now for the number one spot on the list, could it
really be anything other than Dosia’s 200
IQ HE ‘nade from the PGL Major?
(Casting)
And those were our picks for the Top
10 Grenade Kills in CS:GO history.
Did we miss any of your favorites?
Let us know in the comments section below.